liquids they're so liquidy but we've got
a quick and easy way to trap them in
beautiful little spheres no less this my
friends is reverse spherification and
it's a fancy way to package delicious
juices for your dishes start with the
flavorful liquid of your choosing then
drop in calcium lactate gluconate let's
call it calcium salt and blend until
it's dissolved as for proportions you
should be adding calcium salt equal to
two percent of the liquids wait we'll
wait while you figure that out
give the mix some time to settle so air
bubbles can escape be free bubbles next
fill a bowl with pre-made alginate and
two others with plain old water now
you're ready to Speer offical use a deep
measuring spoon to scoop out your juice
position the spoon just above the
surface of the alginate and pour the
liquid in you'll see the liquid form
into a sphere as it drops to the bottom
what's happening is the alginate is
instantly forming into a gel as it
reacts with the calcium ions in the
juice of salt so you end up with the
shell surrounding your delicious liquid
think of it like a gusher fruit snack
only healthier now gently stir the
alginate to make sure the shell is
firming up after 30 seconds of this
transfer the sphere to the water bath
and stir a bit more
then transfer once more to a holding
bath of water with some practice you'll
be able to form several spheres
simultaneously just be sure to
constantly stir the alginate bath so the
spheres don't stick together and there
you have it
liquid finally contained